the book is titled rationality what it
is why it seems scarce and why it
matters stephen pinker is a psychologist
and professor at harvard and he makes
the case for humanity's ability to use
careful thinking to make our world a
better place but first we have to
understand what rationality is thank you
for joining us professor pinker what do
you mean by rationality
i define it as the use of knowledge to
attain goals
that is there is something that you want
to show something you want to
get and you use brain power to attain it
all right professor that leads me to
wonder if people are not using that to
make decisions what are they using to
make decisions if it may right that
seems so rational to use rationality if
they're not doing it what are they using
yeah well sometimes people use uh
impressions stereotypes anecdotes rumors
theories that make your own side look
noble and wise make the other side look
foolish and stupid so alignment with the
truth that is
doing things that actually conform to
reality
we're capable of it that's how we hold a
job that's how we pay our taxes that's
how we get the kids clothed and fed and
off to school on time but in some realms
we aren't necessarily after the
objective truth we may be just trying to
make our own side look good
all right professor if somebody's
watching and they say you know what that
makes sense i want to train my mind to
be more
rational and i want to train my mind to
be able to disregard irrationality when
i see it or hear it is that possible can
you train your mind to do that
yeah and that that's one of the things i
try to convey in my book i try to
explain the major tools of rationality
that don't come naturally to us things
like logic and probability and
distinguishing correlation from
causation so part of it is to have at
your fingertips these tools of
rationality but another part is to
belong to communities of of people that
follow rules that are aimed at getting
at the truth i know that notice that
earlier in the program you talked about
the
court system juries and adversarial
proceedings that's an example of a kind
of game we play where the rules are set
up so that even though no individual
human
has a monopoly on the truth none of us
is perfectly wise irrational we're only
human we're fallible but the other hand
when you have a group of people that are
allowed to criticize each other's
fallacies that gives you some hope that
the group following those rules can be
rational in a way that every individual
person couldn't ever claim to be
all right professor how does rationality
coexist with things that appear less
rational like love or loyalty i mean i
can tell you if my wife employed
rationality she never would have agreed
to marry me because it just was not a
rational decision so
how do we kind of marry up you know love
and and loyalty and other things that
are maybe less reliable
but you know there is a kind of
rationality to it it's not that obvious
but when you think about it if you were
just to choose the you know the the the
best looking and the funniest the
smartest and the richest person that she
came along that came along so far well
by the law of averages someone even
better is bound to come along in the
future and then you should
drop you like a hot potato you'd have no
reason to fall in love with her because
she would not be committed to the
relationship if she loved you just
because you're you you're just that
unique person there that at least gives
you some grounds for committing yourself
to her and of course vice versa so even
in cases of romantic infatuation falling
head over heels there is a kind of
rationality to it in conditions of
bargaining and negotiation sometimes it
pays to be a little bit irrational
well professor i went and watched some
of your videos i mean i i think the
topic you took on to write about
is is fascinating uh my previous guest
was in a courtroom as was i and and we
like logic and we like facts we like
rationality but i i'd really like to
talk to you again some point and and for
folks interested in kind of rationality
and why they need it and how to spot
irrationality in others i recommend the
professor's book thank you for joining
us professor pinker
thank you for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else